listening
outside it says uh this talk is
but it's actually by me soil
and outside it also says that their
applications to prove complexity and
that is true and so don't worry that is
also the Direction with which I will be
approaching the stuff
so to start with uh the talk is titled
lifting to parity decision trees via
stifling so it's really a result about
parity this is increased
um it's the
if the Avenue through which I myself
approach proof complexity so this is
going to be pretty much
um along the lines of my uh
thought process
so just a joint work with arcadev nikhil
and swaggerproof and we'll start with
why proof complexity leads us to think
about right in this entries
so um this has all been said before but
we're just gonna do a quick run through
improve complexity you have in general
an unsatisfiable CNF and you want to
prove that there is no satisfying
assignment and we know that such proofs
should be quite large if we assume that
MP is not equal to coin P at least for
some cnfs
and what we want to do is we want to
prove that for certain definitions of
proofs that we can actually show this
that there are cnfs for which proofs
under this definition have to be large
and the definitions that we'll be
interested in are quite computational
and to lead to this let's rephrase an
unsatisfiable CNF as
the condition that every assignment to
the variables falsifies a clause
okay and this naturally leads us to this
relation the false clause relation
and it relates assignments in 0 1 to the
N to Clauses in your CNF
and the relation is just X is related to
I
if the assignment X falsifies Clause I
and in this language what we want to
prove is that this relation the false
clause relation is total
that is for every single assignment
there is some Clause that it is related
to
and this this is relation and obviously
in Theatrical computer science we're
very much interested in the complexity
of uh Computing relations
and we'll see that in the case of
decision trees
a decision tree that actually computes
this relation is indeed a proof that uh
our CNF is unsatisfiable so as an
example here we'll take the simple CNF
which has three clauses
a decision tree is a way to map
assignments to Clauses in this context
and what it does is it specifies a
variable X1 so you query what X1 is if
it's zero you take this path if it's one
you take this path and you recurse until
you reach a leaf and you output whatever
value there is I believe
so it's clear from this that every input
is being related to some Clause number
so if you give me a decision tree that
part of it the totality of the decision
tree is evident all that we need to
verify is that the decision tree is
actually Computing uh the relation in
question
so we need to verify is that for every
single leaf L the inputs that reach that
specific Leaf L do actually falsify the
Clause that you're outputting over there
so for example if you take the second
Leaf here
every input that reaches the sleeve has
X1 set to 1 and X2 set to zero and that
is in fact sufficient to falsify the
second class over here
so this is just a quick run through of
how a decision tree of size s is indeed
a proof of sizes
um
now they're not just proofs they're
actually well studied proofs they are
exactly tree-like resolution proofs
so this is what a tree like resolution
proof would look like you take Clauses
from your CNF and then you do the
resolution action there's an X2 and a
not X2 here so you can resolve that out
the next one and not X1 you resolve and
you get the empty class and this proof
is exactly the same as this decision
tree it's just flipped upside down these
are the Clauses one two and three this
is your internal node
and this is your root node
and this is two in general it's a quite
simple relationship and since this is
well studied
um it must be the case that we know cnfs
for which uh this proof system requires
large proofs and indeed that's true so
the prison hole principle and the site
in principle or two important cnfs that
we'll be talking about in this talk
so in the prison Hall principle you have
a variable for every pigeon and every
hole
and that variable tells you whether that
pigeon p is in that whole Edge
and what the physical principle states
it states that every pigeon is in a hole
that's basically saying that the ore of
these variables in a row is one that's a
single clause
and the other constraints that you have
is every hole has at least has greater
than one percent
okay wait sorry
no hold has greater than one picture
there is something wrong there so for
that uh that's also quite simply uh it's
a polynomial number of clauses both of
these constraints together cannot be
satisfied so this is an unset CNF and
the question is are there proofs that
every assignment
does falsify a clause in a decision tree
proof and the answer to that is no any
decision tree that actually push this
really needs a very large size
and the other one we're interested in is
the Titan uh CNF
so you have a constant degree graph G
with an odd number of vertices the way I
prefer to State it and there's a
variable for every single edge which is
telling you whether to include that edge
or whether to drop that edge so for
every single assignment to your
variables you have a different graph DX
and you have constraints that are
stating that every vertex has odd degree
so the constraint that say vertex 1 has
odd degree is a constraint really only
on these three edges here on a constant
number of edges and so it can be written
as a CNF of constant size
and so if you take all these vertices
together that's a CNF of order n clauses
and it's proven to be hard whenever D is
an expander this requires large the same
precise
in order to prove this
so when I say this is entry size in
order to prove this that also is what I
mean is you require a large decision
Tree in order to solve the false clause
such problem
all right so this is a quick
introduction to things that we've
already seen
so now I'm going to move on to slightly
uh
stronger proof systems so one of these
is quite common which are decision dags
or just basic resolution proofs whatever
proofs you get just by doing only the
resolution rule
so this if you think of them as decision
trees you have to make some
modifications you have to make them into
a dag format
and from the perspective of a decision
Tree in which you're querying variables
the only modification you have to make
is that you can forget some of your
variables so although you could have had
two different computational paths which
are remembering different things
they can forget variables and reach the
same state which is how it's actually
compressing your decision tree
so even though you're remembering
different things here and different
things here
after some queries if you forget some
stuff it's possible that you're
remembering the exact same state that's
some other point
and what this allows you to do by using
this DAC structure is in this if you
think of it in terms of resolution
proofs it's allowing you to reuse the
line that you've already derived in
multiple derivations
right all of this is really just
background
um but I should mention here that
decision tax do actually give you a huge
saving you can go from exponential size
proofs to poly size proofs by changing
from decision trees to decision bags for
some cnfs
it's not the case for the pigeonhole
principle
and it's also not the case for the
citing principle
but we're not going to be actually
looking too much at this strengthening
of the proof system the strengthening
that we're interested in and what
finally brings priority decision trees
into the talk is if you're trying to
compute this relation by a parity this
is entry okay so this is
really the starting point of the talk if
there are any questions till now before
this
okay so from here on I think I can take
it a bit store
so the difference between a decision
tree and a parity decision tree is that
instead of querying bits you're actually
querying entire priorities so instead of
just being a index of from one to n here
it's actually a subset of 110 and the
answer that you get is the priority of
that subsidifix
and again the the statements are still
as before this decision tree defines the
total relation from inputs to Clauses
and it's easy to verify that it does
actually uh compute false class such
problem
so I will skip over those
now it turns out
that parity the CL trees are exactly
tree like res plus proofs
so in this res plus proof
every line instead of just being a
clause a clause which is a disjunction
of literals now every line is a
dysfunction of paradise so it's X1 plus
X2 is equal to zero or X under 60 plus
X5 is one this is the general format
that you would see of a line
and you're allowed to do the resolution
rule again very similar to the normal
resolution rule where if you have a
parity set in two different ways in two
different lines you can get rid of that
parity and just keep the rest of the
Clauses so that's the resolution rule
one problem is that it's not immediately
clear whether you can do resolution on
two lines because lines can be written
equivalently
so for instance these two here this has
X1 plus X3 plus X5 is one this has X2
plus X3 plus X5 is zero but it turns out
that these two lines are equivalent
so in a parity this is entry uh when you
think of it as a tree like resp we're
actually allowing it a semantic
derivation
so even though it might
um
it might not be of the form P equal to
zero and P equal to one when you look at
two lines
um we're assuming that it can implicit
implicitly figure out whether it can be
made into this form so that you can do
resolution
if you want to explicitly make it into
this form you can do a rebasing rule
which is to change the basis with which
you're looking at disparities
in that case if you have P1 or P2 you
can replace it with P1 or not P1 plus P2
which is exactly what I've done here
so not of X1 plus X2 is 0 is X1 plus X2
is 1. if you add that to X1 plus x c
plus X5 is 1 you get exactly X2 plus x 3
plus x 5 is 0. so the revising rule it
doesn't really change anything because
if you do the rebasing rule to this
conclusion you get this back so these
two are exactly equivalent
and you can also Define parity that's
instead of parity the same trees
and what we know is so there it has been
proven that the pigeonhole principle is
hard even if you use parity the same
trees in the standard variant the site
and graph becomes easy because it's all
about parties it turns out to be very
easily solvable for pdts
but yeah it's clear that we do have
lower bounds against parity this entries
the place where we have no lower bounds
is Clarity Ducks this is just the
resplus system we don't know if cnfs
that are hard for priority decks
so this is the
goal we would like to strive towards but
towards this goal what we want to First
figure out is why is it harder to prove
lower bonds against parity the same
trees or parity taxes
so one reason is that a priority oh
sorry for taking I guess you just ask
the parent is like in sequence and um
yeah so you can you can kind of
can you do something low depth I guess
it's my question like oh you can do that
you can do a binary search and you can
ask like the parity of like this half of
the graph one of them will be odd one of
them will be even and you can all right
okay
so why are party lower bonds harder and
this is
not just the question improve complexity
this is a question I was originally
interested in which led to this paper
which then had applications that proved
complexity and so I'm here so this is
really why I'm here
so one thing is priority constraints
there are correlations between multiple
bits right you're saying that all these
bits together there are an even number
of ones in them
so it's not
it's really not easy to think about
generally you can think of querying a
bit and finding out the value of that
bit and then you you have an idea of
what you know and what you don't know
when you have priority constraints it
becomes just much harder to think about
which is something we would like to do
uh another reason is that there's really
a lot of parity queries that can be made
instead of just being n queries that you
can make there now with this vast number
of queries you can make
and in fact
um there's a famous size width trade-off
that you have for decision uh that you
have for
yeah decision Dax or just for resolution
proofs you have a seismic trade-off and
that proof doesn't work with priority
queries
exactly because there are so many
different priority queries that could
have been made so preparity tags we
don't even have this statement that we
have large width it implies large size
this probably should not have been paid
off it's just relation between them but
not a payoff
so this raises the question
um priorities all these priorities are
strong what tricks can we use in order
to tame the power of these priorities
what tricks can we use to make them
easier to work with
or if you will
um
what are some parity poopers
and that's what this talk is going to be
about we're just going to look at a
variety of different ways in which we
can somewhat tame the power of parity
queries
so we're going to start with this
statebreaker of 867
they prove various lower bounds for
parity the cnps so they show that the
pigeonhole principle is hard they show
for a CNF related to Satan that that is
actually hard for parity of the same
trees
and they have other interesting results
um
generally you would give previous
results then you would compare to your
results and show how your results are
better
both of these authors are in the
audience and I do not fancy my chances
in a two-on-one fight so
um
they're actually all their works are
completely incomparable to ours and
they're all very interesting and I think
that it's really good that we're getting
these various ways to attack uh parity
lower bonds and I think we need more
such ways that's really the goal of my
talk it's a call to action find more
ways in which we can control priority
lower bonds
so let's start with their lower bond for
the pigeonhole principles
so what is the weakness of priority
queries that they exploit
well that's basically this if you have K
parity constraints that are set that is
you have K linear equations in F2 and if
you have a solution here which I'm just
writing as A1 to a n
then for any K plus 1 indices
in this 10 indices
you can find a different solution which
also satisfies the exact same K parity
constraints
what differs only in those sentences so
to be clear um suppose K was just three
and so let's take the set s which is of
size 4. it says that if you have one
solution like this
I'll be able to find the different
solution in which the values outside of
s are exactly the same it's still a one
a two eight three eight A9 A9 A10
but it changes inside s
and the proof of this is also quite
simple
um so what you do is
you add extra priority constraints I was
hoping to write on this but my computer
doesn't work so I have to look over here
which is a bit weird
so just bear with me for a bit
so let's just add uh
so let's add extra constraints for each
bit outside of s
and they're at most n minus K minus 1
bits outside of s
um let's add
many constraints
so those are fixing the bits outside of
s and now the total number of
constraints that you have has gone up to
gone up to at most n minus 1. so now you
have n minus 1 constraints in an N
dimensional space so if there's one
solution then there has to be more than
one solution so there has to be another
solution which has the same bits outside
but different values inside
um
and this fact is used to say that
in the positional principle if you want
to Output uh the false clause being
pigeon p is in some hole it's very hard
to do that so what I mean by this is if
you look at
suppose you're outputting the
pigeon one is in a hole was one of your
Clauses and that Clause is false
well that means that if you look at the
first row of the this thing yeah the
pigeon and all those holes up there
um what you're basically saying is that
all of these values are zero
right but if you haven't made enough uh
priority priority queries yet you
haven't set enough constraints that
means that if you take a large enough
subset here there should be a different
solution to this in which the values
here are different which means that the
pigeon is actually in some hole and so
you could not have actually said that
that is the false Plus
so this is a very rough look at that
lower bound but it's the essence of the
lower Bond
so this is their lower bond for the
prison Hall principle they also had a
different lower Bound for a CNF related
to Satan
um so in Satan we had one variable for
every Edge
so in this new CNF that we're going to
create which I'm calling F here
we have two variables for every Edge
and using these variables you're going
to implicitly
uh Define an XE here so
you take these two variables you take
their and whatever that value is you
think of that as XE and then you try to
think of the set in principle on the
implicit axis
now the statement that vertex V has odd
degree initially it depended on a
constant number of variables XC now it's
going to depend on just twice as many
variables uh in the y in the y world
and yeah so
so basically since it depends on only
twice the degree of wave variables that
means you can write it as a CNF with
only that many clauses
so it's still
f is still a c enough with around the
same number of Clauses and still
constant width
so what is the weakness of Fairly
queries that displayed it here
well here what they use is that if you
have a small size parity decision tree
that computes any relation
then you actually have a small or a low
cost communication protocol that
computes the same relation
so the idea of that is let's take a
small let's take any uh parity this
entry
and let's look at an internal node of it
so this is some internal node V you take
the sub tree rooted at V and you take
the part of the tree that's outside of
it so you're splitting the tree into two
sets
and apparently it's very easy to check
if your input would actually go to this
Vertex or not if you're allowed
communication complexity so if you're
allowed a communication protocol so with
constant communication you can find out
whether your input would have gone
outside of this subtree or whether it
would pass through the subtree
and then you can just keep on cutting
down the size of the tree in half each
time or by constant fraction each time
and so you get the randomized
communication complexity
of the same problem solved by the PDT is
at most log of the PDT size
and then they use another work which
shows that in this CNF you can actually
embed the destroyedness function embed
in some sense
and so since we know that the randomized
communication complexity of this
jointness is large that automatically
implies that the PDT size of this should
be exponential in N to the 1 by 3.
so in their previous work they used this
uh in in the in the previous result that
we spoke about
they were using
great
so this was the weakness of party
queries that they exploited then which
is this nice combinatorial thing
uh
in this result what they're using is the
fact that if the randomized
communication complexity is large then
the PDP size should be large this one uh
it's still important whenever you get a
randomized communication complexity
lower bounded it potentially gives you
something
but I feel that this one is a bit of
Overkill we should not need randomized
communication complexity lower bounds in
order to prove uh PDT size lower bonds
there should be an easier way to go
about it like I don't personally know an
easier way to go about it for the CNF
but there are other cnfs for which we
show that there are easier ways to go
about them
that brings us to our contributions so
what we do is we introduce another a
notion of stifling which helps negate
the power of priority queries that
should be negate the power of fair
decrease it's easy to make it five
degrees
um
and we use this notion of stifling in
order to prove a simulation theorem with
constant size gadgets and this is
something we're quite happy about it's
nice to have simulation theorems which
use content size gadgets I'll get to
what a simulation theorem is in a bit
and
so with these together we show that for
every single uh decision tree lower bond
which is just the lower bound on
tree-like resolution we're going to get
a related tree like res plus lower Bond
or a parody in the CNP lower Bond
and so that so
um that's a pretty large class because
we know how to prove the CNP lower ones
for many uh search problems so this is a
pretty large class of problems for which
we're showing PDT for once
right
right so
from this point onwards the talk I'll
start talking about our contributions
but this is a pretty long talk so I
think I should have many breaks in
between
are there any questions
cycling
the dictionary definition I'm not too
sure
uh suppressing yeah I guess that would
be it yeah so generally suppressing
speech is the normal yeah suppressing
their power to their agency here yeah
often with speech with me specifically
because often with speech specifically
there was a so if you ever saw All in
the Family years and years ago this is
what Archie Bunker used to say to Edith
all the time when he didn't want her to
say something stifled
so that Satan lower bound that you
talked about that was like basically
taken with arm lifting don't say
anything again just Auto curiously like
it's a one sitting with overlifting the
same thing is like is it very important
it shouldn't matter at all you're just
changing the science of America
see about that
should be exercising
I think the way you said it was long
yeah so I think you get a lot of them
well they're like the
Omega and clauses and each one is
important so it's it's Fanny too
how much does
parody of being brought to matters
um so module is really nice because
we're always dealing with Boolean
assignments yeah
other mods are very hard for us to do if
that's going to be one of the open
problems oh
foreign
queries although I described them as
these Global correlations
there is a view in which they don't
actually seem that global
so consider
all your n bit string inputs that's
you're just given and hit an end with
string no constraints on it
and then suppose you query X1 plus X2
plus X3 and you find out that the answer
is one
now this seems like it's a global
correlation it's relating these three
variables X1 X2 and X3 but if you just
rewrite this to just write it as X1 is
equal to X2 plus X3 plus X1
sorry X2 plus x t plus one
this you can think of this as just being
a constraint on X1 it's really not
restricting X2 or X3
it's really weird that it's a change
like this because it's just an
equivalent statement but this is
actually true
um if you just think of X2 and X3 being
unconstrained and just X1 having a
constraint on it you're getting exactly
the set of assignments which uh satisfy
this priority constraint
so the set of solutions to this one
priority constraints is actually 0 1 to
the N minus 1 on everything except X1
and with X1 set appropriately based on
whatever the value is in zero and three
n minus 1.
and whenever you get a new constraint
now
those new constraints are only on N
minus 1 bits so what I mean by that is
suppose after that someone told you that
X1 plus x t plus X5 is 0.
this seems like it's a constraint that
is also affecting X1 but since we know
that X1 is equal to X2 plus X2 plus X
plus one we can replace X1 with that and
this is
given that we have that constraint we
can rewrite this constraint to
completely avoid X1
so what we've done here is we've taken
any parity constraint
we've written it as a constraint on one
variable leaving everything else free
and have the fact that all new
constraints are over only the free bits
so it's really nice it's like you've set
one bit and you have an N minus one
dimensional space to play with
and this the simple fact is going to
lead us to very simple lower bonds for a
parity so let's take this example here
so we have the majority function on
seven bits we want to find out whether
majority of them are one or majority of
them are zero
and we're going to prove a parity query
lower Bound for this function
suppose that somebody makes three
quality three priority queries
um what we're going to do is we're going
to answer them
um arbitrarily we don't care what answer
we give to those three party queries
because even after answering those three
priority queries given our view of
things
we've just affected three of the bits
and four of the bits are still free
so that means that by setting those four
bits to zero the answer can be Zero by
setting those four bits to one the
answer can be one
so really after querying these three
parities you still don't know whether
the output of majority is zero one
and what I really like about this lower
bond is that
it completely ignores the fact that
their priority query is pretty much
and this is the basis for the stifling
functions that we're going to Define
so
a case stifled function is a function
that can ignore any K variables so
majority was very good for us because it
could ignore any three variables and
still set its value by looking at the
other four variables in general we say a
function is K stifled if for every
subset of size K or less
there exists partial assignments to the
other variables
um
which actually fix the value of the
function
right so there's an assignment x0 to the
variables outside of this
such that if you take any completion of
this partial assignment the output of
the function is zero and there is
similarly a partial assignment X1 such
that if you take any completion on the
bits outside of this the function value
is 1.
and this is also why we call it a
probably should be called a stifling
function
so what's happening here is cycling
we're we're saying for any set of s bits
if the other bits collude they can
completely stifle the influence of these
s bits and they can ensure that the
function is set to whatever value they
want to set it
so what we saw earlier was or what's
easy to see is that majority on two n
plus one bits is n stifled
any n Bits I can ignore them and still
set the function value to whatever I
want
and that so for any case cycle function
the PDT complexity of that function is
at least k
so let's take another example of what
the cycling function can be so the
indexing function which is very commonly
used for composition
so it takes a
two inputs really it's or you can think
of its input as being in two parts one
is an M bit string uh and the other one
is a two to the N bit string and we
think of the N bit string as being an
index into the two to the N bit string
it's pointing to one of two to the end
bits and the output of indexing is
basically what is the value of that bit
that is pointed to
um so we can think of it like this and
we're going to show that any n Bits that
you give me are actually going to be
stifled by the rest of the the bits of
indexing
so suppose that these are these stifle
bits that's a bits from X and N minus a
bits from y we want to stifle them
well they're really n minus a bits that
we have no control over we have control
over all the other bits so we want to
ensure really is that whatever X we're
putting in here does not point to any of
these n minus a bits if we can ensure
that then we can stifle it
and they're 2 to the N minus a ways to
set the free bits in x
um since they were at most n minus a
ways to set the bits in X to point to
one of these stifle bits here
the fact that they are 2 to the N minus
a ways to pick the to fix the free bits
means that for most of the ways you fix
the free bits it's impossible to point
to its type a bit
on the N minus a ways of at most n minus
a waves that this could have possibly
pointed to a cycle bit
so
yeah
so we fix any of the settings of the
free bits in X which don't point to a
stifle bit
and then you set all the other bits in y
to zero or one depending on whether you
want the function dot put zero or one
so the indexing function is n stifled
um so what we prove using this stifled
function definition is that for any
relation R the PDT complexity of R
composed with f again L you should
probably get to it that means
um
actually it'll come on the next slide so
the PDT function of of a relation
related to R
which uses the function f is at least K
times the decision pre-complexity of the
original relation
the PDT size of the relation composed
with f is at least 2 to the 2 to the
power K times the same tree complexity
of r
and we also have similar results for
other measures which are also
interesting but
they might also be addressing improved
complexity but we haven't seen the news
yet which is the Subspace the Symmetry
complexity where you can query whether
your input is in a Subspace instead of
just querying a parity
and the non-adaptive variants of these
measures
so let's take our relation R to be the
false plus search on the Satan problem
and let F be any
function that is case type of which
we're assuming it's RT is T here
so again we know the variables that are
involved in Satan which is a variable
for each Edge
in our R composed with f
we're replacing each variable for in r
with t variables
and the idea similar to what we had
earlier
is that we're implicitly defining what
XE is using these T variables and using
the function that we're composing with
so the XE variable is implicitly F of
uh the y e variables
again because
all the Clauses over here were just on a
constant number of
variables XE we can again make exactly
the same argument here and say that the
number of Clauses that are going to be
used
that are going to be needed to represent
R composed with f is going to be at most
two to the time 2 to the power T times
how many ever classes were used by r
that was very uh
that wasn't very mathy but I hope it's
clear
and again the width of the Clauses is
small so
if we can
if T is a constant this is all very nice
for us and
T is actually going to be a constant
whenever we use it
and one important fact that we want here
is
if you find a falsified clause in this R
composed with f it actually gives you a
falsified clause in r
so to see that we can think of
let's just look at what R is R has a
bunch of Clauses so you see one
and C2 and C3
now for each of the Clauses here
we had a bunch of Clauses that came out
of it let's say b11 D12 and so on
each of these gave rise to a bunch of
buzzers and that's how we built our CNF
for our composed with f
and if you
run the if you compute false Cloud
search over R compose with f it'll tell
you hey one of your Clauses here was
false and if this Clause here is false
it actually implies that in your
implicit X
that this Clause is false
because this is a CNF and this is an and
of constraints
so if you find a falsified clause for
your are composed with f it actually
does give you a false phase clause for x
so this brings us to how are we actually
going to prove lower bounds
in general like before we figure out how
we prove priority the century Lord wants
let's just talk a bit about lower bonds
in query complexity in general
but before that I guess I'll stop the
questions again
by composition sure
um so composition here is
exactly this so you have some
computational tasks you're working on
here here for instance you have r
and our takes as input uh
n variables or M variables there's one
variable for each Edge over here
so you can think of that as X1 X2
x m
and by composition
I'm not actually be I'm going to define
a new uh relation which doesn't directly
work with these inputs
so you can think of in these two reasons
so earlier what we had was all of these
were being used to compute
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
replace each of these with an instance
of f
foreign
Ty
or M1 y n
so
we're dealing with this new this is what
we call a composite uh relation where
its inputs are these y variables and to
Output
an answer
okay
we actually we can find out what the
valid outputs of this are by actually
Computing F on these y variables getting
a bit here and doing them for each of
this and then using that as an input
first item
that's what a composed relation is
and
what this last line is saying on this
slide
it's saying that if you solve the false
clause search problem for the cnfr
composed with f
it's actually Computing this composed
relation of Satan composed to that
so how do you prove lower Bonds in
general
so very similar to the proverb delayer
game you can think of the querier
adversary game
and it's probably exactly the same game
so the queryer makes queries to your
inputs the adversary answers them what
the queryer wants to do is it wants to
Output some value it wants to Output an
I such that for every single input
that's consistent with all the queries
and their answers till now
I should actually be a valid output
and if the adversary can force the
queryer to make quick K queries before
answering that means that the dysentery
complexity of the task was at least K
and in fact it's an if and only if
as an if K is the maximum number of
queries that the adversary can force
then the decision tree complexity is
exactly equal to K
so the question now is if you want to
prove a lower bound uh what kind of
adversary do we need how can we force
the queryer to make many queries
how are we going to be in adversity for
this computational task are composed
with that
so let's just take four bits here so
there are these implicit bits X E1 to X
E4 for each one page of the edges and
there are these t-bit blocks that
correspond to each of these axis
and whenever a new parity query is made
what we're going to do is we're going to
do exactly what we did for the majority
function
somebody a new priority query is made we
answer it arbitrarily and we think of it
as just affecting one of the bits and
the rest of the bits are completely free
so say maybe it affected that bit over
there
and every time a new priority query is
made it might affect uh one more bit
somewhere else
um so when I say a new priority query I
mean a party query that's independent of
all previous parity queries if your
priority query depends on your previous
parity queries you already know what to
answer
so these are generally new priority
queries
whenever a block has K bits affected
where f is a case cycle function so if
suppose this block gets too affected
what we're going to do is we're going to
query
um
xei so here that's the second block
so what I mean here by query xci we're
in adversary we shouldn't be querying
anything so what we're going to do is
we're going to simulate a query or
adversary game for our mentally so we're
going to think of an adversary for R and
we're going to ask it
can you tell me what the value of the
second bit is
and it's going to give us some answer
whatever that answer is because our
function is a k stifle it means that we
can fill in the rest of the bits here in
in order to ensure that whatever answer
was given to us
is actually consistent with whatever
bits we have here
so once we've done this step of uh
querying xe2 and setting the remaining
bits in order to ensure that the output
is exactly what the answer was
we've ensured that you know everything
is for sure
yeah
and now these new bits uh the new bits
that we set we also think of them as
conjugate so now when I say a new parity
query is made this new priority query is
not just with respect to the old parity
queries but also with respect to the
extra bits that we set it should be
independent of all of those
right so that's a it's a very simple
strategy for us we're just answering
queries arbitrarily and whenever some
block gets too affected we're just
setting the rest of the bits in it
and we're going to show that this
adversary is actually gives us all the
results that we wanted
so suppose the person the queryer made K
times the decision tree of our parity
queries
that means that the number of
so this means that the number of uh
marked the number of uh blocks where K
parities were marked has to be less than
dtor
what that means is that in our internal
simulation we have made less than DT of
our queries to the adversary for r
and because of the very definition of
the our adversary this means that we
don't know what the output of the
function is
you know in our internal game where
we're querying the axes we don't know
what the output should be and since each
unqueried x e i so suppose I've made
these queries and these are all set so
this is set to zero in each of the
unqueried axes
we can still independently set them to
whatever we want again because of the
case type of nature we can just set the
free bits to set them to whatever you
want
and so we can actually get any
realization of the x's on the free bits
so that means that even the person who's
doing the priority query still doesn't
know what the output of R should be
so we cannot answer r and therefore we
cannot answer the answer of our composed
so
yeah
it should really be that we as the
adversary cannot answer R and therefore
the query cannot answer our composite
false function construction
yes so this uh I chose to give a dual
view where
the adversity
so generally when you look at simulation
theorems from the seminal papers uh
they're presented in a different way
where you're simulating at this entry
rather than simulating the adversary of
this entry
but I felt that given that we're
actively stifling it makes more sense to
present it as a person in the site right
it feels more natural in this case
it's possible if someone gives a really
nice presentation of the Dual way I can
switch to that to me that's pronounce a
little better
yeah so this is the proof that the
number of queries needed
the number of queries that the party
queryer needs to make is at least K
times with this entry complexity or
so this is proving that the PDT number
of queries needed is large this isn't
proving that the PDT size is large and
what we want for proof complexity is to
prove that all pdts need to have a large
size
and that actually it's it's really the
same simulation so if you if you want to
do the same argument and show that the
size is large
what we're going to use is the fact that
we could answer these new party queries
arbitrarily we're going to be a bit more
clever here in order to prove that the
PDP size has to be large
and we're going to do a thought
experiment where the queryer is going to
use the optimally sized priority the
symmetry so we we all know what the
optimally sized priority the same
difference is for this problem and the
query is using it
and it's reached some point where the
queryer makes a query this is at some
point in
in the process of following the PDT it
makes a query
what we're going to do is we're going to
answer it not arbitrarily but we're
going to answer it in such a way that
the queryer is going to go to the
smaller side of the tree so if t0 is
smaller than T1
we're going to answer it so that the
answer is zero so that's it
and what we what we gain by doing this
is we're forcing the answer to be
revealed in just log of PDT size queries
because every time it's making a new
query we're answering it so that its
size is happening
so that means that the query is actually
going to try to answer within log of PDP
size queries
but nothing has changed from our earlier
argument it's still true that
um
they need K times this entry complexity
of f many queries before they can answer
so that means that the log of PDT size
has to be at least K times with this
entry complexity of f which is exactly
what you want that's PDT size is at
least 2 to the power K times this entry
complexity of f
it's a very neat trick that you get just
by changing what we mean by arbitrarily
um size is the number of nodes
since it's a tree we didn't don't make
much of a distinction here we just keep
it as number of nodes
I mean I guess everything I said would
still work with number of lifts you just
go to the site with the smaller number
of leaks
right
um so this brings me to this ends the
proof of the simulation theorem for the
size version
and it brings me to an out of body
experience that I once had
around like a little less than a year
ago at the band workshop for
communication complexity
so uh this result was being presented
and I had this experience as if I was
sitting in the audience
and uh doing this presentation
and it was a bit unsettling until I got
a ping from one of my co-authors dude
this sounds exactly like the sort of
stuff we were doing
so it turns out that the same result was
got by Paul beam and Sergeant Kurt and
it was actually Sergeant who was giving
the presentation and I was actually in
the audience
yeah they had a result they were looking
at the indexing and inner product
functions and various properties related
to lifting and
the structure of these functions
and one of the results that they had
along these lines was that yeah if you
use the indexing function as your
composition then you actually do get PDT
size of our compost with indexing is at
least two to the power of the this entry
complexity or
so
we then coordinated and got our papers
out around the same time online
yeah that was a that was a fun
experience
so
um
so that's all
I wanted to say about the simulation
theorem
um
but I have there's still a lot of open
questions related to the simulation
theorem and one of them is to do with
this inner product function itself
so the inner product function it
it takes us input two t bits and what it
asks is can you tell what the answer is
of summation x i y i mod 2. so that's
how many indices here have both of these
bits set to one we want the answer to
that modulo two
and this is generally a very hard
function it requires you know T
communication complexity so it requires
T priority this entry complexity and so
on
but interestingly
um if you look at how stifled it is it's
really not that stifled it is one stifle
if you take any one bit here I can set
this other bit to zero and therefore
make that bit completely irrelevant and
set the function output however I want
but it is not too stifled
if you take these two bits here I can
put whatever bits I want over here but
these two bits have enough power to flip
the answer so I can't set it to zero or
set it to one
so this doesn't give us as strong a
lower bound that you want it does give
us a composition with inner product
so we do we'll get to the parity the
same three complexities at least the
disintery size of the relation but we
don't get T times the this entry size
which is what we really want
um yeah
so in this case
what other priority Cooper can we find
that can actually prove this result
this is
I feel like the more ways we can attack
priority the better it is for us in
general
and so I think of this as despite it
being like a toy question a pretty
important problem there are many other
properties that we should be able to
exploit what are they
so this is the least important but my
most favorite of the open problems
um we haven't seen it yeah I mean
foreign
so the the parity query
uh you know you should be you should be
safe because the the only bad thing
would be if you ask both of them but but
if you asked the parody of it then you
could do one one or zero zero
yes
so you make February it's going you
think of it as affecting one bit
and you don't wait for more purpose
queries to remain you just set the a
little bit to zero and continue
and until yes I suppose you made T minus
one queries it sets everything here
you still have enough power to
0 and 1.
no no what is the parities
sounds
oh yeah okay
this works
it's more involved process for the
adversary but
it's still a very interesting
can you do something for your theory
it's a good level
um yeah so I guess this
would also work
I'm just a bit disappointed that we
don't have a new property a priority
that we're using here do you get an
issue with doing the size version of it
there may be queries that happen or
younger to go to the smaller side I
actually am just forced two times
whenever this thing is being marked as
read or is something that's been
concerned we can go to whichever site we
want to and then set the value of the
other one principle
because if the parity just depends on
those two pairs yeah then if you set it
to zero then you are forced to go take a
sign of one
so that'll get you the decision
treatment
you can be
sorry could you explain again why it's
not too stifle but obvious why this is
not stupid uh so suppose you're trying
to cycle uh these two bits here
so by the definition of cycle it means
that I should be able to set the rest of
these bits in such a way that the
function value is already determined
and it determine just zero and determine
to one depending on what I want but the
thing is no matter how I set this you
can set this to uh say zero zero in
which case
[Music]
so suppose you set this in
in a certain way and we have summation x
i y i
for everything except the last
coordinate suppose that is equal to B
module
if this is set to 1 1 then the answer to
inner product will be B plus one
um and if it's a page anything else it
would just be B12 but instead of the
other way around that like somehow that
you want to fix those marked bits first
and then you don't want to use the other
bits too
we're just marking them as effective
bits because they're affected in a very
complicated way they depending on the
conservation of other things we don't
want to deal with that wow oh that's why
I get it okay then I see it's a
different definition okay
there's just don't mention something
this might be random but there's like an
old pic some old papers by name maybe
other people that look at like um you
take something that's hard for True
resolution and then you lift it with
something whatever and then you look at
it you look at like a tree like a
pregnant person where you're allowed to
query or something from some class
what you require is that this really
strong correlation lower bounds uh
between the
Gadget function and the something you're
clearing
so in other words if you if you're if
the function that you're allowed to
query can't really
can't really
get to the values index standard of
every budget is it doesn't help much in
distinguished yes we put lower bounds as
long as we hope is strong Average status
it feels like maybe it does it probably
does as a special case so I'm not sure
if it may bring it up just because maybe
it's a more general definition cyclists
so but when you're doing the so some
some suddenly you're you're whenever I
get a party query I like pick a bit then
that's sort of the parity of the other
guys but and this choice is somehow
being made for us adversarity I mean
we're not trying to do it in a smart way
we're just you know picking the first
guy say and it's like even because
sometimes if you were doing lower bound
and and in fact we are picking the bits
we're sort of committing towards a
function of the other bits I would try
to avoid getting a column like this but
you might not be able to somebody might
have queried that column
and then all the other variables are
like totally free that's what I think it
was
so one thing about this stifle just
because we had this whole discussion is
like you said inner product isn't too
stifled uh because it was two bits
um but it is too stifled if I add in uh
you know a new constraint which is
instead of letting these two things be
set however I want I'm going to add some
uh you know I have a parity constraint
determining the top one I'm prepared to
be constraints bottom one I'll throw in
a third parody constraint that says the
parity of the two of them is one for
example at which point these necessarily
gets zero when you uh take oh I see the
product and now you can continue on such
so somehow you know it's about two
Staples it's very close to being you
know T minus one side fold
as far as parents
as being some kind of problem standard
product where some constraints are
already made on
oh I'm saying you know you could imagine
how you know I'm simulating a decision
tree so as long as you haven't forced
those two bits
I can just say all right you've queried
uh these two bits I'll give you a third
for free you know uh you know as a
president but it has to be like
compatible with the consent that they're
making yes but
yeah then I'm fine if you fix those two
bits then you know you just get a
slightly smaller right so yeah if it's
more query like then it's more
videos
it's hard to say what they're doing
experiences
um could you do something like you say
um I only query so I think there's a uh
that says
if you're in any Subspace that
sufficiently high dimension the inner
product is not yet fixed
so could we wait until a parody can
trade is about to to lower the
dimension of a particular block
below that threshold you know and then
fix that fix
the bit in that block that's to be
however we want
I think I'm talking about it
that's not what you do
yeah
okay
but a parity is simultaneously looking
at various blocks right yeah but but
um
you could just
say
as long as there does not exist a box
where if I restricted to that block
I'm below the threshold then it doesn't
matter all the blocks are all the inner
products are kind of free
it's only when a block becomes it's
about to become critical that I say
forget about the the you know now look
at the constraints in that block that
affect that block
okay and
um
I'm just going to like simulate remove
that set of constraint of T constraints
by just fixing the value in that one box
this might work if you're creating the
boxes
okay but they could be priority
constraints that have made correlations
between blocks which well but but you're
saying saying we're just gonna
okay
I'm not sure if you're done or not
okay okay
there's a problem with the way we fix
variables Dags
this has actually already been proven uh
PHP requires large mod pdps
by part number
and it uses like the first trick of
priority this entries that we looked at
where uh if you've made a few
constraints there's always another
solution
um
yeah
[Applause]
by release
so the width of a line is just a number
of parties
so when I was asking just
yeah I mean if you want to think about
it I mean I guess it's just the
dimension of the Subspace like if you
think about it as a each line as a
Subspace it's just a mention of the
papine subspaces involved in the sorry
code dimensionally I find Subspace is
involved in the proof
foreign
[Applause]